hey guys in this video i'm gonna give
you my
full grooming routine from the beginning
all the way
to the end i'm gonna throw in a few
extra tips as well
so that you will look your best let's
not waste any more time
let's get to it
[Music]
all right now i workouts first thing in
the morning
before the extreme heat of the day and
before all the unexpected things of the
day
jump on and it helps me to stick to my
daily routine
as well then when that's done i jump
right into the shower
i wash my hair every two to three days
because you don't want to wash it every
day
and my face every time after my workout
and then right after the shower i shave
my facial hair
why right after the shower because then
my hair is still
soft and it's easier to shave first i
shave with a razor the space between my
beard and the hair
on my head right on the sideburns why do
i do this
because then it stands out more your
beard stands out more
and your hair on your head stands out
more as well it looks more
neat more professional and more stylish
next i go and shave all the hair here on
my cheeks in a nice straight line
from my ears to my mouth all the hair
above this line
looks unneat and it needs to go next i
move on to the hair on my neck
everything below the double chin area
here needs to go and please remember
don't shave off
all the hair here just below your chin
especially if you're a bit overweight
because then you'll just show your
double chin
more look in the mirror with a straight
posture take your finger and put it
under your chin at the top point of your
neck
above the adam's apple and shave
everything off
below it on your neck next i need to
trim my beard so i bring out my trimmer
and i start below the ear and trim my
weight down to my chin
while i adjust the length of the trimmer
while i go down
why do i do this because then it starts
short and it goes
longer towards my chin to me it just
looks more stylish and i like
this style and it fits with me it might
work for you
it might not when that's done i put on
my face cream that helps my skin to look
clear
and fresh it also helps those pores to
shrink
and keeps the pimples away and then i
move over to my beard oil if i stay at
home
or this styling bomb if i'm going out
now when that's done
i move on to style my hair first i make
it a little bit wet with water
and then i add a pre-styling product
like sea salt spray or mousse
which will help me to style my hair a
lot easier
then i just use a blow dryer to blow it
in the style
that i want it to be sometimes i like a
side part style and sometimes
i just like it top messy maybe a cliff
and then when it's dry i use fiber or
clay to style it
and lastly i use a little hairspray to
keep it
in its position now just remember i'll
add all the product links for you in the
video description
as always so it's a bit easier for you
to go and check them out i'll also
add some great alternatives for you as
well and now
the last step clone if i'm using a
cologne with a very
strong smell i only spray it three times
i spray it once below each ear
and on the back of my neck and then if
it's not that strong
five sprays below each ear
on the back of my neck and on both
collars
around the collars the smell on your
clothes will last
a lot longer than the smell on your body
is one of the reasons why your
girlfriend or your wife
might like to smile your clothes every
now and then i don't know why
almost all of them do it it's very
interesting but yeah they do it
now always remember this your grooming
will never be more important than your
kind humble
and confident personality great grooming
only enhances it
i'll see you guys in the next video
cheers